you know where you are you only I was
trailer commentaries for Jumanji welcome
to the jungle baby yeah hey guys welcome
to what I just said the show where we're
gonna talk about the honest trailer for
the new Jumanji movie so go watch that
first then come back here and watch us
talk about it
we'll wait we'll wait and you're back
and stick around to the end of this
video you'll see some deleted scenes
jokes we cut stuff that wasn't good
enough yeah but that you want to see
anyway for some reason you're here
yeah that's Joestar hey I'm Spencer J
Gilbert dan myrtles at screening but
let's just talk to you mangy without him
cuz there's not too much to say about
this movie it's a fun romp yeah it was a
it was a it was a fun little thing
called Jumanji that have anything to do
with the old thing called you mangy but
whatever I was gonna say well it took
place in the jungle but the first one
didn't take place in the jungle came to
you came to you yeah this was perfectly
fun this was like guardians to to me a
little bit Rose like her ray and then I
never thought about it again yeah but
that's like appropriate for just a
feature-length action comedy delicious
piece of cotton candy that was nice and
then it's gone exactly but gigantic
movie huge huge huge hit head legs oh
yes a lace multiplier yeah thanks to the
rock and Kevin Hart who dated before
with Central Intelligence and like a
vintage Jack Black performance came on
yeah yeah no that wasn't waiting for
because he did like that polka King on
Netflix that was rough wait for that
that that big jack black people tell me
Bernie's really good but I still haven't
I still haven't seen Bernie dipped in
you I don't think anyone who's told us
Bernie was good has seen Bernie that's
my theory
yeah but we saw this movie and when you
see a good movie these are like the
hardest ones to write honest truth is
about because like it's pretty good yeah
I know there's also it's a comedy like
you don't want to make jokes about
things that are already jokes
yeah jokes on jokes is weird
you don't want to just sit and ding on
like this looked weird or this is in a
slightly different place but what we do
is we do a little judo a little like use
its momentum and throw it over our heads
with us to just talk about other movies
and other things inside of the film it's
so flexible you can do these forever so
we use this to talk about the rock to
talk about video game movies and yada
yada yada you get in it let's get into
it
that's Jumanji ourselves a house trailer
hands I need cash Oh God so I'm prepared
[Music]
from the studio that just can't seem to
launch a franchise or comes to reboot no
one wanted that ended up being really
fun and something I wouldn't mind seeing
more of is this is this what hope feels
like Jumanji welcome to the jungle buzz
if they made two Manjhi I'd watch it I'd
want you [ __ ] out of it yeah totally
this is I mean the premise they have to
kind of tie themselves in knots to get
these four actually no you just get four
new case yeah for two people whoever
when they make the new one whoever's
like I mean there's not gonna be a next
Rock but who's ever sort of in those
spots just throw them in or it's just
like a different game same characters
like what was the spiritual Jumanji
sequel a thorough thorough yeah all
right I just want the Third's ather to
come out so that we have Zathura that'll
be a good movie to mangi and then
Zathura
there you go sony we gave you a preview
a universe so I think the opening of
this honest trailer was I think I just
asked you hey man what's your prod take
on Jumanji and you were like I don't
know it's pretty good and I'd watch it
again and I don't know that makes me
feel hopeful and I was just like what
funny names would you call the rock they
should record everything I say which
they do on screen junkies pretty much
90% of the words I speak throughout the
day are right here yep our lunches will
be live stream soon and it's gonna be
good
behind the fork yep all right let's keep
going you love the 1995 original now the
reboot is tossing out the setting the
premise the dead kids the Robin Williams
and pretty much everything except the
name
but since I swore a blood oath to see
every movie the rock makes here we are
mean for teenagers it's not fully true
cannot see the rundown watch them Lauren
of course just like The Breakfast Club
thanks to an action-packed day in
detention just like that other movie
believe it was called Power Rangers buzz
is that not so secret I've stolen so
many Simpsons jokes for honest trailers
there excuse me I've put so many
Simpsons references it not as trailers
only the the Simpsons fan can find in
this case it was the bus the couldn't
slow down it's a really speedy film the
bus has to speed the area it drops under
a certain speed is it's so true The
Simpsons did it in in all comedy you
make 900 episodes and it's just in my
blood I can't help myself
is this permission to just start
cranking Hicks Hank Scorpio lines yes
you know we're fully out of ideas
yeah just Popeye Popeye II for like 3
minutes in it all right keep going
Power Rangers you must be a bully of the
tension real as each team is Jumanji
into an avatar that represents their
character arc the nerd who needs courage
the jaw who needs humility the weirdo
who needs confidence and the popular
girl who needs to learn how a penis
works so how do we do this oh my god
these things are crazy it may be on the
nose but you'll laugh as all the actors
get to play against their usual type
don't cry don't cry don't cry don't cry
don't cry I like can't even with this
place except for Kevin Hart Kevin Hart
oh these pivot chords
Oh Kevin get him to do the board game
that literally rebooted it social
invigoration sorry i wish the kid
version of him who was like eight foot
four had also just played himself like
Kevin Hart yeah that would have made
more sense right because everybody is
the opposite yeah personality and
physicality but he changed physicalities
but maybe that affected his personality
because he hid behind his athleticism so
it's kind of confusing because like the
act the joke is like these actors are
not who you think they are like the rock
is the oh he's scared of everything he's
getting hurt Kevin Hart what do you
think of when you think Kevin Hart what
did you get in this three out of four
before him yeah the board gave that
literally rebooted itself or a new
generation that's sort of a riff on the
Trofeo games something I noticed that I
didn't believe Jumanji turns into a
Atari 2600 game yeah early or a
Commodore or something old-school that
he's then playing on the PlayStation 2
controller keep going
River rip on the tropes of video games I
think he's an NPC except when it drops
the pretense to be a normal adventure
movie again I got away I lost him in the
jungle wait why are the NPC's talking DJ
nevermind talk to each other we still
does a good job poking fun at female
heroes designed by dudes why am I
wearing this outfit in a jungle scripted
events doctor briefs tone
Jumanji needs you Jalan she needs you do
need them you know and multiple violent
deaths that never seem to face the
characters pause for a second oh boy so
this movie tripped me out because the
Rock's name is Spencer Gilpin yes when
we first watched it the first time they
said Spencer Gilpin we're like wow this
is gonna be the best on its trailer
they weren't saying Spencer Gilbert no
so close so close but so Ramon I think I
may have just made this up or been
hearing at third hand or something that
it's a reference to the Spencer who is
on harmontown that podcast that the
screenwriter put hit that Spencer in
there is an easter egg but uh someday
someday it'll probably be like a smarmy
shitty critic character like in the
movie it's like oh you'll never do
something good Batman yeah oh god the
guy from honest blunders is here I'm
gonna get so owned just a matter of time
you're gonna get Bishop level owned
comes the jump let's keep going you know
if Mario was real he'd never stop
screaming hey I don't want your pause
what Mario is that scream from I think
it's a they added some reverb to that Oh
God
because that's Mario was just Super
Mario that's brothers no yes it should
be jaunty music not Mario 64 oh should
always just be jaunty Calliope music
yeah no that's pretty haunting and hit
it sorry real he'd never stop screaming
after 35 years Jack Black finally
returns to the jungle just can't get
enough in the third chapter of his
secret jungle quadrilogy gentlemen your
celebration of his rock appeal as Dwayne
Johnson spends an entire movie
discovering the joys of B Dwayne Johnson
whether it's his arms
Jesus Rick universe either laughing
realizing he has no weaknesses
none his sex appeal
or the effect he has a large bearded man
damn that is a man right there you'll
totally buy into the height that's going
to make him the second least qualified
president someday so gear up for a flake
that surprised everyone at the box
office
pay proper respect to the original mrs.
Allen Paris's house I'm just living in
it and reminded every studio that when
most of your reboots feature-length
comedies and video game movies are
terrible will slob all over you just for
showing basic competence now that part
was oh the build-up to that yes story
rocky player1 the cake is a lie cake
tenacious OMG amy respond america that
was uh her doctor who name is character
from Doctor Who's Amy Pond right and
it's video game movie so goddess pond
mmm lay upon words if there's one thing
I'm good at its thinking of words that
sound like other words mmm Portman toes
if you will neologisms if you will a 40%
success rate if you may have okay I got
it
Doctor Who Bing my references American
Harry Styles Gus grimly too many cooks
the Jungle Book the game the movie the
reboot the video game and getting up
there because we did that for Angie good
news keV we've got him on the ropes
Wow maybe the biggest bummer of an
ending we've ever had no it's nice yeah
always go out on a we broke the
extinction joke yeah well we do yeah
yeah we sure stuck it to Jumanji and the
African white where I know yeah I don't
teach you to exist on our planet and I
feel good about both yuck let's see this
what we left out of this this little gem
perfection yeah story the rock hunter
romancing the rock rock a dial Dundee
mini-fridge
it's man's learner's jet black mirror
hash tag bring back Sophie what a great
show selfie are you okay
I always forget to ask him I used to let
you guys pause it was a remake of my
fair lady starring her in John show it
was actually really really good
but with selfies she was like it was the
worst name it's like how cougar town was
not about a town full of Cougars biggest
mistake yeah it's whoever it was like
what is this selfie terrible name
really good show okay man I'm gonna be
thinking about that literal cougar town
premise this town's full of cats okay so
it's Courtney Cox and then nothing but
Cougars actual Cougars actual Cougars
yeah I'm into that yeah that can come on
after MasterChef dogs which I am trying
to push across the finish line here do
you eat the dog no no it's just dogs
cooking you ever seen a dog cook no it's
not why it's gonna be so good just 20
dogs running around in a kitchen while
Gordon Ramsay just shouts at them it's
gonna be just like put that spatula down
yeah that's gonna be so good God's plan
Jeff cosplay let's make it happen
dream with me all right you're right
honest trailers are short shorts new
Efron the Joey's bro Tim Hanks what was
the Jost brush I the Jonas Brothers name
only
he's the Jost brother fall this isn't
that Joe Jonas
I don't know no he's Nick Jonas now
whatever well then he's the second Joey
uh yeah we didn't use it that's why it
didn't make it in didn't make no goddamn
chance the editors are like these boys
don't know their Jonases now it's it's
inky stinky and Nick yep yeah inky he
went too soon did he die I don't know
that's the Hansen brother do you think
the who would win in a fight the Jonas
Brothers of the Hansen's Hansen
hands-down yeah are the Jonas I don't
even think the Jonas Brothers are real
brothers now they're real are they real
yeah okay they're in like a weird
polygamous marriage thing with each
other mm which gives them a strange kind
of strength yeah but I still think
Hanson because they've turned into like
a jam band and like they've probably
seen some [ __ ] yeah definitely like yeah
and the back streets
yeah the county fairs county fairs I
once killed four men during extended
Bongo solo and it pop into the next
century
are we even talking about Jumanji
welcome to the jungle a good movie a
decent honest trailer and a fine
commentary you know it was a good video
several times where Spencer pauses and
just says what was I gonna say I was
something that was important up for the
trailer truth be told I like I like to
be surprised by a future comedy that
makes me laugh thanks for chuckle my
yeah a little more yeah exactly
no this is perfectly fine rocks fun in
it they're all fun in it yeah nice
little surprise I hope this was nice
little surprise for you sticking around
this long because you get a tease for
next week which is like what are we
gonna do it's gonna be great oh the one
we're gonna show them yeah yeah nice oh
man that one's gonna be good
we'll see you here next week hopefully
with Dan to keep us in line see you then
[Music]
you